ما هي أفكارك حول مفوض لجنة الاتصالات الفيدرالية الذي
يدعو Apple و
google لحظر tic tac من متجر التطبيقات الخاص بهما
هو أن الشيء الذي يمكن
أن يحدث بالفعل ،
أنت تعلم جيدًا أن لجنة الاتصالات الفيدرالية ليس لها
دور تلعبه في تنظيم
خدمات الإنترنت مثل متاجر التطبيقات  لذلك
بالنسبة لمفوض لجنة الاتصالات الفيدرالية لتقديم هذا
الطلب
جديرًا بالنشر بالتأكيد ، لكن ليس من الواضح
كيف ستدخل لجنة الاتصالات الفيدرالية
نفسها
، وكما أشرت إلى أن المفوض كار
هو جمهوري في وكالة
يسيطر عليها حاليًا الديمقراطيون أم
أنها رئيسة الحزب الديمقراطي جيسيكا
روزنورسل هي التي ستكون  وضع
جدول الأعمال في لجنة الاتصالات الفيدرالية ، لذا حتى لو حاولت لجنة الاتصالات الفيدرالية
المشاركة بطريقة ما ،
فأنت تعلم أنه سيحتاج إلى الحصول على موافقتها
للمضي قدمًا في أي شيء ،
لذلك أعلم أن هناك الكثير من
الفضائح حول البيانات وشركات التكنولوجيا الكبيرة هذه
لقد غطيت العديد منهم ،
هذا مختلف أه تعلم أن
هناك آثارًا للأمن القومي
على مستوى المستخدم الشخصي ،
هل تعتقد أن مستخدمًا
يهتم بالخصوصية  من الممكن أن يحتفظوا ببرنامج tic tac على هواتفهم في الوقت
الحالي
بشكل جيد ، وأعتقد بالتأكيد أن أي شخص يتمتع
بالخصوصية
يجب أن يلقي نظرة فاحصة على جميع
خدمات الوسائط الاجتماعية التي يستخدمها
ويفكر بشكل
نقدي في المعلومات
التي يسلمها وما إذا كان
أو  لا يعتقدون أنه من الحكمة لهم
أن يستمروا في فعل ذلك
أنت